on the hill they call him ground chuck
but he has definitely remade himself
over the last few years charlie morton
left-handed batting kevin biggio digs in
now the pitch
swing and a miss
he struck him out in an elevated
fastball in vizio he's out
the 80 million dollar man will make his
blue jays debut on the mound tonight
andy diaz in the lead off slot the pitch
a swing of this at a change-up diaz with
a big hack at the change-up thrown by
ryu and he's down on strikes the first
strikeout in the new career for hinjin
ryu is his first batter face
and the rays have runners on the corners
with two out
bring up hunter renfro
who came over to tampa bay in one of two
off-season trades they made with san
diego
2-2 pitch a swing and a miss
change-up away renfro chases it
[Music]
jun jin ryu
strikes him out stranding that lead off
double we're going to the fourth inning
it is nothing nothing jay's and rick and
the blue jays have the bases loaded and
nobody out here in the fourth end
here's randall grichik their home run
leader a year ago
here comes and it's swung on and lined
into left field that's a base hit picked
up quickly by marco so vlady is held but
into score is kevin biggio with the
first run of the 2020 season it's an rbi
single for randall grichik and it puts
the blue jays on top one nothing in the
fourth and rowdy teles comes to the
plate
rowdy weighed back on that one and hit
it deep enough into center
dear meyer make the catch easy tag and
score for vladimir guerrero jr
putting the ball in play gets another
run in two to nothing
hernandez with runners at first and
third and one out first pitch to him is
hit in the air high and deep to left
field marco back in front of the track
he makes the catch
and tagging and scoring is travis shaw
back to back sac flies for the blue jays
it's three nothing and this is how you
take advantage of your opportunity
here's mike brasso
pitch is lifted to the air right center
field of the wide open space heading
back near the wall is bridget and he
plays the hop off the 382 sign more goes
around third he heads for home and he
will score mike rosso josh in the race
first run it's three to one toronto
and here is kiermeier he was the
possible go ahead run
the curve ball swinging a miss and jin
jin ryu
snaps off an even better one and kevin
kiermeier has no answer
two on and nobody out craig kevin bishop
will be the better the pitch cabin
rockets one in the air down the right
field line hooking off into the corner
goodbye
it is gone for kevin biggio
a three-run laser down the right field
line
powering toronto in front six to one
the rays keep the inning going for yoshi
tsutsugo
runner goes the pitch here's a swing and
a high fly ball left center field and
deep that's got some carry that baby is
gone
josie zuzugo
with his first big league home run it's
a two-run homer here in the fifth and
the rays have cut into the lead they're
down six to three
looks like brandon lau is to grab a bat
the pitch
is a fastball right down the middle
strike three call
on the top of the order and beau bechet
coming around
the pitch breaking ball tapped in the
ground to the left of the mound gonna be
a tough play for thompson bare hands
throws the first and he got him nice
play
by ryan thompson
hops off with that mound a bare-handed
grab and then
a bullet the first to take care of
beshetting he gets out of the sixth
inning
unscathed
land the rich extends it
geeks pitches richard swings and listen
to the air shallow center adamus out
here comes caremeyer he's got to play
and he makes it to retire the side
coming straight back in towards the
infield no runs one hit and one left the
blue jays have left five
we head to the homestead with our first
seventh inning stretch we've waited
months for this and now
let's see if willie can keep this line
moving
now this stretch by deleting the full
count pitch to a dominus swing line
drive left center that gets down for a
base hit mark goes around third stumbles
heads for the plate the throw goes to
second
in the score is margot loud a second and
stops rbi single adamus and it's 6-4
toronto now it's up to hunter renfro
last chance in the eighth three on two
out
here it comes
strike three called a fastball 94 right
over the outside black knee knee-high
probably dolisa's best pitch of the
night the rays leave the bases loaded
and they're going to the ninth at the
truck the rays are going to be able to
bring the tying run to the plate and
brandon lau
now giles doesn't have to deal with any
traffic here's the pitch
slider swing and a miss to finish the
ball game
the first victory in 2020 belongs to the
toronto blue jays on opening day
ken giles comes in works the ninth and
locks up a 6-4 winning edition of blue
jays baseball tonight